well it was it wasn't it funny to how
the second that she felt threatened or
there was any kind of uncomfortableness
she threw in her sick mom right into
them my mom's sick my mom's sick yeah so
shallow and weak well guys don't do that
unless they're someone makes a mom joke
and you're trying to nail him back like
my mom has cancer yeah
in in that case it's funny this next
guest a returning guest and last time he
was doing something different he's just
he's everywhere now you can find with
Anthony ku Mia calm he has a podcast
they're not for the faint of heart and
if you're watching the video cast he's
wearing an incredible get up Gavin
McGinnis thanks for being on da doo da
da ba ba da no I did too but that's what
you were telling me about the the fries
you ate and it's given you bags we yes
flowers Ramones did quit I don't know
what was with them but uh we were
judging it's comedy roast which was
pathetic by the way and my eyes started
getting itchy and then by the time I
walked out of there I could barely see I
put Preparation H on my face and a
benadryl but I'm still like look I look
like a I'm incredibly embarrassed all
the time I am you should feel that way
regardless
yeah people listening to wrestling
what's he talking about you can see the
video cast at lotta with greater calm
could just be an MSG thing I don't know
I mean you should be of good stock
considering you eight boots in and
Montreal your whole life there should be
nothing maybe it was the dip I don't
know it's I mean I guess it's boring to
talk about but I just want to explain to
all the women there who were hoping to
use this material that's why I'm so much
uglier than usual alright so you have
the podcast now and Anthony Kumi a
podcast network you're working with
rebel media up there in Canada great
people we kind of touched on this last
time you you you're you were born in
Scotland I want to make sure and then
you moved to Canada
my parents are Scottish they went down
to England and had me and then in the
70s Canada was desperate for educated
citizens because they wanted to build up
their computer industry computers for
hot and so they just went to British
schools and said anyone here interested
in physics or engineering or anything
science
see and some people put up the hand they
go come on aboard we'll pay for
everything and they sort of built these
suburbs cord in these British immigrants
and made Canada and I'm then bombard a
happened yes that's pretty it's funny my
uh my ex-girlfriend her grandfather who
actually fought for Hitler and I think
may have gotten some Hungarians killed
when he moved to Montreal he was looking
to he want to get a job and so they were
building I don't know if it was the
Champlain Bridge no it was a Victoria
Bridge and he said you know I've humped
a job you know they said okay see if you
can walk up at that scaffold or whatever
they call it with a bridge there see if
you can walk across that and walk back
if you can you'll get a job so he walked
up and he came back and said okay had
the job it turns out about half the
people just fell and then they opened up
Bombardier and was it to Pratt and
Whitney
Pratt and Whitney was another one and he
went in there started working the floor
and then he became an engineer he became
an actual engineer there so the American
success story back then could still be
had in Canada but that's what I was
gained when you and I were raised there
a lot of people raised in the United
States don't realize how quickly that
can go away I mean you advice which you
created you started up brought it to the
States because the opportunity just
wasn't there in Canada do you feel
concerned with like a Bernie Sanders or
Hillary Clinton that that could happen
here Oh totally I mean if if she wins a
Bernie Sanders can't win if he did I
don't know I don't know I think he might
be here in the primary I don't know if
he became the next president I mean we
already had a socialist president for
eight years
can you imagine what you do it would be
like when Breitbart died I'd be in a
daze for three days I've said this about
Bernie Sanders and people are going to
get really mad and I'll be audited it's
the first time where I would think of
renouncing my citizenship and leaving
because I mean you know if you run a
business typical day for me is 14 hours
right now I haven't taken a two day
weekend and over a year I'm not gonna
put that work in so a guy like Bernie
Sanders can take 90 percent as he claims
to want to do I think you'll see a lot
of people because he's really extreme
even more so than Hillary if that's the
case and he gets what he wants I would
only have to consider that is that
unreasonable I mean it seems hyperbolic
but who knows maybe you should leave I
don't know and then you present tax he
wants to put he said if he could on the
top you know top 1% top 1% is all
household with over 500 thousand a year
top 10% which he's proposed 70% tax is
any household making 150,000 a year
anyhow while making 150 thousand a year
you're in the top 10% well we saw what
happened with France there was a mass
exodus right I mean same with Britain
the Rolling Stone said we love Britain
we just can't afford to live there so I
think he little if he does try to
Institute that it can't last because
everyone with money will start
disappearing and they'll take their jobs
with them but there's a disconnect I
mean you're young you're hip you're with
it see you got the facial hair you're in
Brooklyn there's an entire generation of
people again who aren't weren't raised
in Canada so they don't see how quickly
it can happen they don't understand that
a 70 90 percent tax that you you can't
pay for the things he promises I don't
know if you've seen the the we did the
math breakdown and his plan was um 18
trillion dollars in additional debt to
running our current deficit over the
next 10 years if he cut military
spending by a hundred percent taxed all
earnings over a million dollars by a
hundred percent you still couldn't pay
for it but people don't care well it's
really the death of math I mean right we
used to push math hard in school and
people understood numbers now no one
cares about numbers so 30 million
immigrants or 1 million immigrants no
problem
18 trillion it's just a big number that
make can a rich guy pay it how much does
a rich guy have done it doesn't he have
like 17 trillion no yeah billion and
I've heard Hollywood liberals say this
they just need to tax a few rich guys
maybe George Soros and Warren Buffett
could get together and pay off the debt
in an afternoon they you could bleed
every billionaire dry and you'd barely
take a chip off of it right the left
takes advantage of this with immigration
and with with the the debt where they
know that no one's gonna check the
numbers same with education you go how
much does the average American kid get
per year and they go I think it's about
13,000
thousand a month and they'll go I don't
know 400 bucks and then just try it just
lie and go it's actually 50,000 and
they'll go oh and I go should it be more
and they go yeah
100,000 per student and they'll go there
is no limit the children are our future
I'm just you don't understand
two plus two is four well it's a
brilliant system they'll think about it
I'm becoming less and less convinced
that college is a necessity let alone
even valuable for a lot of people but
it's a brilliant system get them into
university but it'll be indoctrinated at
a relatively young malleable age and now
declare it like Bernie Sanders a human
right or even Clinton is going that way
a human right so they feel entitled to
free college and they come out and you
have a voter base you have a voting base
for years whereas if you look at kids
you go to trade schools who ultimately a
lot of them end up opening up businesses
they're more successful it used to be a
point where was about the same or a
little bit less as more studies come out
it's turning out that there are actually
more job opportunities that pay better
for kids and trade schools and college
but no one talks about it well yeah
there's this I think with boomers they
saw that the ones who had an education
made tons more money so that became you
need an education now college is almost
a victim of the free market because they
went when we have high standards we
don't get that many students so why
don't we lower the bar and invent a
whole doctrine here of other courses
like when I was in school there was the
philosophy of self was a class yeah lots
of be of love was a class now we have
classes like how to be gay is the class
that's true you texted me that because
you told me I said I'm I sent something
homoerotic and you said you had learned
how to become gay hey [ __ ] Josh OS deep
it's humid here in New York to believe
that that's terrestrial oh sorry say
that in Quebec you can say that on I
don't know what cou Mia does over there
but over here the swear word sorry
you know I'm french-canadian it's not
you see it on primetime TV oh really
yeah the F word they to use it like a
period you know that you can turn it on
to tell a wait did I say the F word yeah
you did you said that many also said SC
wow that's weird sorry what that um
so I don't know if it was a grande
Marxist scheme or if it was just they go
hey when these people are idiots right
there into idiocracy so let's feed them
idiocracy let's have these terrible
courses that are totally useless where
they come out dumber
when then when they went in and it
perpetuates itself because there's this
myth of everyone needs education and
it's even more untrue today than it was
before because the education you're
providing is all [ __ ] and they have
these guys who they don't that we're
short on tradesmen and I see these I
have friends of mine that have nothing
going on their lives because they're not
that smart and you go you would have
been an awesome welder and you've had a
happy life my buddy is a blue-collar
electrician in the Union he makes more
money than I do and I know a lot of
lawyers who make 40k a year well it
depends where you're going
starting salary if you're like Harvard
or U of M I think it's 160 they must
have gone to a crappy school man there's
a glut there's too many lawyers yeah I
know you're telling me we have feminists
threatened to sue us all the time I
don't know what it is they must get they
must get all the pro bono work in the
country these feminists 3 I constantly
get requests to remove their image we
just had well yeah it's right you were
text me asking what was that image with
the feminists we had a feminist who put
out this image of her giant fat self
with a t-shirt that says I'm an effin
feminist and she used it to promote her
I think stop and stare clothing line so
we're like well this is perfect for a
feminist meme and we added some text and
then she claimed that her mother was in
the hospital and it was causing her
great anguish to remove it and as a
courtesy I removed it but then I
realized she was probably lying and you
asked me you mean he said what image was
it and I said it - you said uh yeah I'd
use it but if she commits suicide that'd
be a real liability yeah cause it
happens with these feminists like when I
showed up in my underwear in this video
for those you haven't seen it you can go
to the website and see the video it's
perfectly legal right to be in your
underwear you have the suit that guy in
New York the cowboy but feminists can
say oh it caused recall to rape and so I
feel like it was sexual harassment and
they can claim rape to a cop and then
you end up in a situation because they
just don't believe in language anymore
they choose to make it up as they
well it was it wasn't it funny to how
the second that she felt threatened or
there was any kind of uncomfortableness
she threw in her sick mom right into
them my mom's sick my mom's sick yeah so
shallow and weak well guys don't do that
unless they're someone makes a mom joke
and you're trying to nail him back like
my mom has cancer yeah in in that case
it's funny we had this thing just so you
know the whole deal with Dov Charney
right well which which deal so AAA
American Apparel wanted him out oh yeah
yeah yeah I needed a needed an excuse so
they said it's all these sex sexual
harassment lawsuits right cuz he was mr.
illegal immigration yes so this the
lawsuits were long dead but they kept
coming back and I think one of the
reasons is I put these pictures on my
site
one is of Kimbrel Oh nude getting [ __ ]
by double sorry cuz I'm getting sorry
sorry
making love to do and the other ones are
from this other were girl Irene Morales
and she is pleasuring herself and that's
relevant because they went on Good
Morning America or one of these these
shows you know just in little Hillary
Clinton suits and said Kimber Lowe said
she was raped and Irene Morales said she
was a sex slave so the pictures are from
the sexual encounter she's talking about
about who's it's not rape and the Irene
Morales was sending him disgusting
perverted texts after she was done
working at American Apparel so I would
never put up pictures like that normally
but they were relevant to the case and
they're asking for a quarter of a
billion dollars from Dove it ended up
ruining him he's got no money I don't
think that was a four hundred million
dollar company it's about to file for
bankruptcy
American Apparel is yeah I didn't know
that one of the biggest charges was
Kimbrel Oh tried to kill herself
I believe so now it becomes a criminal
act which is why I said that to you
about that picture yeah but yeah merican
apparel is on the outs they always funny
they came you know they they grew more
popular in montréal OTT of people don't
realize that Montreal there they're
behind as far as technology but they're
way
had as far as fashion and American
Apparel was huge in Montreal before they
started setting up in malls here in the
states and yeah that's what David Z's a
Shimada Jew and that's a classic
Montreal guy the HUS the Jewish English
hustler and when you apply that guy
who's but perfectly bilingual it can
hustle and get through the dirt around a
bureaucracy
he just murders in a free country like
America well let me we have to go keep
the lights on from these evil capitalist
sponsors Gavin McGinnis we'll be back
after this stay tuned and we'll we'll be
sure to keep bleeping him back with
Gavin McGinnis you know it's funny we're
talking about American Apparel because
this is interest something I find
interesting about you what is what do
you do what's with that face what are
you doing these bags this this this
allergic reaction makes yourself I don't
know but benadryl is what I imagine a
hangover would feel like I've never
actually been hungover but benadryl just
ruins me for the entire day
no no benadryl you're just sluggish a
hangover is like you're being sued and
the mob just put a hit out on you and
you can't find your son
he's lost I don't know if that's quite
if I would go that but possibly I don't
know see that's the thing that's a
perfect leftist argument it's like you
haven't done heroin how can you have an
opinion on it being legal well I guess
you're right I haven't done it so though
pretty much everyone who's done morphine
is effectively done heroin little known
fact heroin was developed as a synthetic
non-addictive alternative to morphine
talk about a screw-up I want to go back
to American Apparel because that's
something I find really interesting that
Americans might not know now you're
pretty profane guy you're pretty rough
around the edge around the edges but
you're also a man of faith and you've
talked about how you're kind of growing
in that - you came - it came back to it
a little bit later
I'm back came to it came to it yeah it's
true I guess I guess my dad said that
mean baptizing my kids was child abuse
and but he doesn't think third term
abortions are bad good lord
nice definitions of abuse huh I hate to
tell you your father's a sick man
murders fine splashing of water is abuse
yeah that's that's
little bit bizarre okay so you came to
faith later on but American Apparel is
interesting because their ads have
always been risque here in the United
States but I remember there was an ad in
Montreal and I went there was an ad of a
they sell these sort of mesh body suits
and there was a girl on all fours from
behind no underwear and this was you
know the size of an entire wall and I
remember just pointing someone there
saying hey listen obviously I don't care
I like looking at that I'm a guy
biologically but a kid can walk in here
man you goes well we're very very
forward in our advertising and as
someone who is personally pretty edgy do
you see that though as sort of a problem
a sort of a cultural pulling at the
twine of the fabric I mean Montreal our
Times Square is club super sex is strip
clubs and it doesn't have good
ramifications does that is all at all
concern you with our generation here
it's something I would imagine you have
an interesting opinion on I don't want
kids seeing porn that involves
fornication but I have no problem with
the human body and I thought those ads
were all pretty tasteful I mean the
woman looked sexy but I don't see that
nudity is is no this was different the
one I'm Tom I was actually in the store
and it was literally a girl picture her
from behind on all fours you could
basically use it as a as an anatomy
chart oh you can see her you could see
her nether regions entirely yeah isn't
that illegal
none will not Montreal I mean think of
the signs for the strip clubs there or
the moving neon hand with the but in
Montreal it's like it is so awful and
when I tell Americans they don't believe
me like I'll know you're good at your
name what no no no no no no I'm not and
it does take away innocence when there's
a barcode for phone electric is is a for
fun the entire but or is it more
specific I you know it's funny remember
everyone's like hey I want to go to
foots and I was that straight-laced kid
I was like no I don't want to go to
fluffs cuz weird stuff happened there
and yeah it's I mean as someone who is
more sort of libertarian my approach to
enforcing any kind of beliefs I also see
the negative ramifications in Montreal I
mean Montreal is actually people are
going to get mad at this you know this
French Canadians have about the same
teen pregnancy rate dropout rate and
abortion rate as black Americans
that's the single highest demographic in
all of those you know anywhere really in
the industrialized world Quebec has the
highest abortion rate in the
industrialized world if you were to
judge it as a country and you've got to
say well this hyper sexualized culture
at some point has got to have something
to do with it yeah I mean it's a tough
subject as a dad because before all this
I didn't care about any of it I thought
it was all totally rad and I still I
mean we go to this anarchist communist
sometimes in in England where this band
crass built a sort of a they call it
dial house and there's tons of kids
running around and a lot of the people
are nude so they'll just you'll be
talking to a nude guy and there's a kid
running in the background I don't see
anything wrong with that it's totally
asexual but I'm the same way yeah really
no I mean I would do that and I also I
remember my dad you know I started out
acting was like well would you what
would what's your line I said I would do
a full-on streaking you know my doneger
showing if it was supposed to be like a
frat scene and it was a dumb idiot I
said but the moment you get into
something that's sexualized particularly
if I'm married I wouldn't I wouldn't do
any of it so I would sooner be
completely nude running down the street
then I would be doing any kind of a sex
scene even if there was no nudity in a
film and we're because I had to think
about those things and my dad said oh
okay that's that's fair
is she square - you think that's clear
no I'm just asking
my dad is he's actually called into the
show he's he would he swears almost zero
but when he does it punctuates a
sentence and he's probably - left us
probably the most offensive person you
could imagine but he's never dirty well
my dad's never not dirty and my parents
were always nude when I was a kid
they're still nude like if they come to
visit I'll be my mom we'll be walking
back from the bathroom and I'll see all
our geriatric genitalia but uh farts I
forgot what I was gonna say let me tell
you this about my dad they give me an
idea my dad I remember um he gave us he
gave me the sex talk when I was three
just so you know so he just said you
know we don't want you to think of it as
anything dirty at all but as a Christian
he wanted me to understand the
parameters that he thought and he raised
me to be appropriate for sex so I had it
at three and actually got
they called home in preschool because
they were doing historic business and I
corrected her with medically accurate
terminology so my dad was never and he
same thing in church he would get in
trouble for just telling people he's
like hey this is he would be really open
about sex but he believed it was between
a husband and wife but he was never
approved about it
right well I'll tell you I'll never see
anyone happier than a young Catholic
girl who churned out a bunch of kids
early
unfortunately that option is pretty rare
these days especially in New York City
you know and I I'm of two minds about it
I mean I'm definitely not scared of sex
oh that's what I was going to say there
is a real latent Puritanism in America
that and it's shocking coming from
sex-positive Montreal where it's the
right and the left are both really
uptight about the right just can't
handle any sort of nudity and any kind
of allusions to sex and the left has
this whole no means no and like I just
heard today on AIM and yes means no and
yes means no and loving it and then
regretting it eight years later means no
and you go you just sound like the
sexual Puritans on the far right even
there was feminists saying that the
kiss-cam oh my gosh you know hold on a
sec we have to go to a break let's go to
the well for those listening this will
be available online at a web extended
version where Gavin will go into
conservative and leftist sexology
uncensored stay tuned we'll be right
back thank you for watching this video
and taking a break from salacious
internet pornography we know it may be
by accident but we appreciate it anyway
and you can watch one of these other
free videos or click Subscribe by
punching my face with your mouse that's
kind of fun or punching the subscribe
button where we've actually written it
out for you it's all free but there
probably aren't going to be any
breasteses